We have just seen how we can load images from
files stored on our computer into the MATLAB
environment where we can begin to look at
them and manipulate them, but for a robot
it is really important that it is sensing
the world as it is now. So information that
is stored in a file may not be sufficiently
up to date. We need to see the world as it
is now: we need to be able to bring images
in from a camera.
Now it is really fortunate today that almost
all computers have one or more cameras attached
to them. So what we are going to look at now
is how we get information from a camera on
my computer into the MATLAB environment.
So here we are in the MATLAB desktop workspace
again and in order to grab an image from a
camera we first create an object, a MATLAB
object that is attached to the camera and
in this case, it is the zeroth camera—that
is the first camera that my computer has.
And it creates a new object in the MATLAB
workspace, an object of type VideoCamera.
As soon as this object has been created, the
camera attached to my computer has become
live; a little red recording light has come
on. This object supports a number of methods,
and the most important method for our purposes
is the grab method, which grabs an image from
the camera, the most recent image from the
camera, and displays it.
We might be interested in actually putting
the image into a workspace variable and we
do it in this way. We assign the output of
the grab method to a workspace variable and
in this case, the variable im, and the image
is grabbed from the camera and placed into
that workspace variable. If I call the function
again it will take another picture and display
it with my head in a different pose.
The camera is running continuously. In order
to turn the camera off I need to destroy the
camera object. You do that with a MATLAB clear
command, so if I clear the object from the
workspace the object is destroyed and the
camera is turned off. The red light disappears.